[Music]
good afternoon folks where we'd like to
introduce you to the basics of essary
today at least how we do this at Google
so reliability obviously it's important
to us a lot of things keep us up at
night we want to make sure that we don't
have our judges because of lack of power
we want to make sure that a bad code
release doesn't completely stop us in
our tracks we want to make sure that we
don't lose a bunch of customers during
Black Friday because we have gotten
overloaded and cannot serve capacity and
just latency goes flat and nobody gets
responses so at Google we approach this
with the establishment of the site
reliability engineering group and who do
we who are we to talk to you about this
I'm Jess frame I've been at Google for a
bit over a decade half as a developer
half as asre
working in platforms and cloud and
social and few other groups in cloud
I've actually worked on app engine
networking and the customer reliability
engineering group I'm with right now
which you'll hear more about later hi
I'm Anne Wallace I am a cloud consultant
with professional services at Google
I've been at Google little less than a
year and prior to Google I spent 14
years at Nike in various operations
engineering and architecture roles so
today we're going to talk about five key
areas first we're going to talk about
the core problems that sre solves second
we're going to talk about the key
principles sre uses to keep systems
appropriately reliable then we'll dive
into the responsibilities and expertise
of that sres have fourth we'll kind of
pull this together and talk about how
you can adopt some of the sree practices
within your organization and then lastly
we'll talk about how Google could help
you with this
so let's go ahead and get started
talking about what sre is but you know
first let's talk about what makes us
unreliable and how sre helps to solve
these things I'm gonna see this thing
works Oh perfect so oops
we went back it's skipping sorry about
that okay here we go
so traditionally product development
teams or engineering teams spend a lot
of their time designing developing new
features for projects and applications
but once those are ready to go into
production that team those teams
typically move on to the next scene and
really the majority of the total cost of
ownership of software is after it's in
production so if you think at one month
the development time is really equal to
ten months of production support so if
these engineering teams aren't managing
the software once it's in production who
is I'm not gonna use this clicker sorry
about that
all right so again we have the
developers who are working on the new
features and once those are ready to go
into production they kind of throw it
over the proverbial wall to the
operations team the operations team they
deploy into production but more than
deployment production they're the team
that's responsible for the reliability
scalability and maintenance of the
software and more than just a software
it's the servers and services and
infrastructure the the software is
running on and in my experience there is
a lot more emphasis put on hiring for
the develop development teams and the
operations team so you get a lot more
features going over to the operations
team the operations team can't juggle
everything that's going on it causes a
lot of friction between these teams and
it's just not scalable it's kind of a
fragile my model here okay
so reducing the product lifecycle
friction so a lot of these so we start
with the business a business or product
management teams are the ones that make
these feature requests that then go to
the development teams development teams
and implement these features which then
gets handed off to the operations team
so you have these barriers between these
teams a lot of frictions so we have we
have
agile the agile methodology that breaks
down the barrier between the business
and development teams but it doesn't
really help with the barriers between
the development operations team
so this is where DevOps comes in so we
think of DevOps
really in five key areas first we want
to break down that wall this helps with
the collaboration and velocity between
the development operation team second we
know we know things are going to break
we plan for that we accept failure as
normal to smaller changes are easy to
implement and deploy which is awesome
makes them easier to rollback which
helps us with the mean time to recovery
for we want to remove human error from
the equation wherever possible and we do
this leveraging tooling and automation
and fifth we want to measure everything
because measurement is critical to
determine success especially these first
four areas so the sre approach to
operations we sree like to treat
operations as an engineering problem we
hire people who don't want to do
repetitive work and we'll create
automated solutions we use data to guide
decisions and help prioritize what we're
going to work on next next slide so what
do SRA teams at Google do the SRA teams
are not simply just engineers who carry
the pagers sre folks are systems
engineers who develop solutions and
manage large distributed complex systems
at scale the SRA teams at Google have a
saying where they like to automate this
year's job away because there are more
interesting problems to solve the next
year so if we think of DevOps as a
programming interface an SRE or class
essary implements DevOps DevOps is
really a cultural practice that breaks
down the silos between not just the
operations and engineering teams but
your network teams your security team
architecture teams and site reliability
engineering is a set of those practices
we found to work and a job role so now
I'm going to hand this over to Jess to
talk a little bit about the key
principles of Sree
oh cool that work mine is also doing
doubles okay sweet fun so um much of the
feedback loops that drive our paradigm
have to do with the era budget and we
don't expect you to know what this means
at all right now so we want to from the
ground up establish the significance of
this with you and how we came to this
conclusion so first of all our goal is
reliability we need to go through and
determine how we measure this the user
is the most important feature in all
this so the naive approach doesn't
always work for depending on your
service depending on how its distributed
good minutes in total minutes was
historically a very common thing but
this may actually not be a good
representation of user happiness so
instead we like to step back ask you all
to step back and think how the users are
interacting with the system and instead
figure out what the interaction
measurement is and set whether that's
quarries or uptime paying or other
things if you're more of an MMO but so
yes so this moves the whole focal point
of the success measurement away from the
underlying individual machines and code
and off to what the user actually sees
and we all know whatever we measure is
what ends up being optimized for so
making sure this measurement is done
well is the most important thing so
reliability is often presented as a goal
of nine so you've probably seen this
thing before honestly it looks big and
scary particularly when you get up to
three 9s being nine hours of outage year
but even at Google for a
measurement five nines is only
maintained by a small number of teams
this is partly because it takes a lot of
money to achieve that so the underlying
infrastructure is the most important
thing to get moving with that but also
honestly your individual services the
reliability of your ISPs and cellular
networks and everything else often will
hit before that and people can't tell
the difference so what about a hundred
percent we really the world is not about
a hundred percent it is nothing is
certain
our advice from running years and years
of large-scale services is it's not
worth the money it's near impossible
even if we as humanity had the
technology it comes at a hefty price it
comes at very slow change and features
feature features that's not something we
want and each of those nines is really
an exponential cost it's not linear you
can spend all of the money in the world
trying to make something just count a
number and not to fail ever so we were
talking about availability our SLO our
service level objective is actually what
we termed this internally it is our goal
the main consequence for this is shame
internally because we have high
standards for ourselves the indicators
are the metrics and other signals that
we use to measure this and display it on
graphs and do the quarterly reports the
s the agreements the SLA is end up being
what's often shared with external
customers and the consequences of that
with legal teams involved tends to be
money so again focusing on user
happiness getting a good SLO is not as
easy as it seems but the most important
thing to start with is keep it simple
and your you will iterate through and
get something more and more solid
without backing data it's
you revise you learn that's the only way
to go forward with it for example it may
be unintuitive that you can set a low
SLO and achieve it every day but if the
user expects higher of you you will get
complaints before your pager goes off
and that is a very large issue so vital
to the SRA approach here is that we get
these three groups in agreement it's not
going to be easy but it is without these
three being on the same reliability goal
and with the promise to support and
defend each person that's trying to
maintain that we can't move forward if
we don't have agreement if we don't have
supports it doesn't matter if we're
handed the keys to the system we won't
be able to work on it properly it's hard
to get this agreement but there's
luckily a few tools that can be used
with this one is pointing out the
exponential cost to the to the business
people if they want a hundred percent
that's that's going to be very very
expensive and chances are they don't
want to spend the money on it there's a
trade-off between reliability and speed
with the developers and they probably
want to move fast and in all of this
system the users will push back with
unhappiness if it is not reliable enough
and they will go all the source so this
whole system will iterate but you can
get there so having decided on a target
and going through how we measure it and
having an agreement between the three
groups we're going to get back to the
error budget which really is the reverse
of the availability target and what this
is is how much time you can be down and
how many requests you can fail in order
to further getting releases out faster
change progress all of that because we
want to build things we don't actually
want to say no to you ever we have
common goals here so
the era budgets luckily make this nice
feedback loop of having shared goals so
we have less conflict and less churn
we're all on the same team here we all
want a successful product no matter how
much the the office people look like the
bad people to say no we've had too much
downtime you need to cut off and not do
any more releases the developers and
others eventually learn that this is all
for the good of all of us this whole
thing encourages more responsible
expectations and velocity as well from
the various teams so we were going over
the develops principles earlier this is
kind of how the air budget paradigm fits
within them so you get the ownership of
the silos you get the air budgets
themselves which quantify which is vital
and how you measure the reliability is
very important so the concepts of best
flow in an air budget are all well and
good but what do we actually look like
day-to-day is our job we're going to go
over the our areas of expertise here
although where the lines are drawn vary
from company to company I've seen a bit
of variety there so most of those are
pretty obvious metrics are common
capacity is necessary helping with the
change management Emergency Response is
kind of our bread and butter but culture
is one of the interesting ones that
isn't always pointed out but is actually
the most vital and everybody is
responsible for it it's not just the
sres without the culture being supported
by the business and developers it really
it's hard to continue so monitoring
alerting pretty basic we do suggest two
different
priorities paging in tickets depending
on how bad the system is hurt right now
or if it's impending to avoid in the
future and the most scary thing in the
world right there is noisy urgent alerts
that is what will burn out your your
people this is what will end up with
your system not getting the attention
that it needs there's a relevant story
here about crying wolf but still I see
this pattern a lot of just a whole bunch
of little alerts that are treated urgent
and the same level as the whole system
being down so obviously to serve traffic
it's going to take some resources and
ones either gonna have to solve this
with planning your resources overtime
auto-scaling or just having absurd
amounts of capacity in case you have
large spikes to avoid outages the last
option definitely does not become a
possibility the larger you grow though
and the planning becomes more and more
vital at that point even if money isn't
an issue tracking on the resources is
absolutely vital so you can see when
something happens if it is a feature
that you want launched and you're
acknowledging that that was a cost you
had to it or if this is a bug that's
just going to get worse and worse say a
memory leak different teams handle this
differently we prescribed by rollback
immediately when we see something bad
and investigate then so working together
with how changes are introduced working
together with the development teams
often actually means we can combine the
infrastructure and allow the developers
to move faster which isn't as intuitive
but there's normally a lot of
low-hanging fruit there as far as things
that will both make the SRS and the
defect
as happy now some of those are
progressive rollouts and all of those
other things a lot of that allows you to
test to on a smaller pool and confirm
before saying you release the FASTA get
the release out faster so we all want to
move faster despite common
misconceptions with us re and the
developers can move as fast as they want
in our paradigm actually the big wall
there is the error budget and if the
error bridge it gets hit they have to
freeze and they have to freeze until
it's recover it again so most dev teams
this is a nice feedback loop of they
prefer to take a partial hit and not
fully freeze but know that they're near
the budget because if they never
actually exceed they don't have to stop
if they exceed they have to stop until
it's recovered again so that if you're
it's a bad enough outage it may be a
month until you actually can start
releasing your features again which is
something nobody wants so provisioning
the having the capacity is one thing
making sure that it is obtained swiftly
and that when it is actually integrated
into the system that it doesn't break is
equally important to having it in the
first place if you have an outage
because you added a new region and the
system isn't expecting it that is
possibly worse than actually not having
the capacity at all and just dropping
the extra queries so what we are into
who most for is emergency response but
surprisingly this is actually largely
training and support is responsible for
our success I've had a lot of good
developers that were hesitant to
I being on call try the SME role at all
but we have this lovely program
internally called Mission Control and
we'll bring them over and the majority
of them are able to do on call a number
of the most hesitant ones actually end
up being the best of our s Ari's which
is a really exciting thing to see and
it's a matter of not panicking making
sure we have support knowing that you're
not going to be blamed if you reach out
the system is more important than you're
your own ego you're not going to be
harmed financially for it either so so
starting with the outages and the
post-mortems afterwards we need to
determine how bad an outage actually
needs a post-mortem it's very important
to be clear on consistency of incident
size and a standing definition for the
clarity of all parties involved on what
to expect post-mortems are probably the
most vital part of our culture is how we
learn from what's happened in the past
it's the most frustrating thing in the
world to repeat outages whether it's the
exact same one or a pattern over and
over again we're here to learn more
things and make it more stable so this
is one of the big scary ones culture
wise this is something that's hard to do
it's not easy
the our job is absolutely impossible
without support of our choices though
when we're on call we can be handed a
big system if we're not handed the equal
trust and responsibility to go with that
system then we are afraid to make the
choices that are necessary to recover
the system well instead stick to what's
documented stick to what's we know we
won't get in trouble for as opposed to
taking our knowledge of the system and
doing what we need to patch it again and
this is valuable not just during the
outage but at all times which includes
during the post-mortem unavoidably some
of our day-to-day work will be ops
that's how it goes we are part software
engineer we are part systems engineering
ops the the important thing here though
is that we need the support to make
choices on what to automate and win so
we can take away all of these manual
repetitive tasks and instead spend our
time on better things without that
you're not going to have a system that
skills you're just going to throw more
and more people into the bucket until it
actually gets fixed and the best of your
people will end up board which and
mentioned earlier we have better
problems to fix next year the team
skills we like a 50/50 mix this often
means when you're converting from a
traditional ops version actually keeping
all of those off spiegel almost all of
them will be happy to work with you and
their knowledge is absolutely invaluable
everybody should be able to code we do
kind of enforce that's but that is also
so that the system engineers don't end
up with all of the Alps work we we want
to be treated as equals we want the
respect to be in both ways we don't want
a bucket the work that's not a very that
creates silos that are unnecessary it's
not very team like and again we will
point out that empowering the sres and
is the most vital thing in the world for
this if you punish the sres for doing
their job if you don't give them the
necessary escalation tools if you don't
back them when they say this is too much
the system is gonna fall over you're
gonna have an outage they are the people
who know most about this and you have
this trust in them so recap of our SRA
principles and some of the examples of
how that comes in and again pulling back
to DevOps with a few more examples of
how we have the SRA paradigm applied to
that cool so you have all that right so
now we're going to talk about how you
can get started taking some of that what
we've talked about and use it in your
organization okay
so first start with these four things
start with service level objectives SL
OHS are the combined agreement between
the product
dev and sre teams without SL OHS you
don't have error budgets having both of
these helps prioritize the work to hire
system engineers who can write software
they're gonna end up automating a lot of
that manual work that was done
traditionally by the ops team three
treat your product and operations or
system engineering teams the same we're
all we're all software engineers at the
core we want to have respect between the
two teams not have that wall that you're
just throwing crap over and then four we
want to make sure that the sree teams
are able to choose their work so for
example if the Air Bud just continually
get it over it get exceeded in the the
products engineering teams not helping
out the Nasari team should be able to
deprioritize support for that service
s-series are valuable and scarce so we
want to use their time wisely so you've
got this you know pick one service pick
something simple run it through the saw
remodel make sure that your team feels
empowered that they have support from
management and so forth I mean you check
and make sure that your services are up
and running make sure you check in with
the team health because change is hard
we all have to adjust things are gonna
fail things people are going to make
mistakes through this process that's
okay and using things like the blame is
post-mortems helps just it's an
iterative process but once you feel like
you've kind of got this
in it doesn't have to be perfect become
the internal advocate take that service
that you've run through the sre model
and start talking to other teams
internally you're gonna find people who
are excited about this and they're gonna
be your people you they're gonna be your
internal advocate team and you just keep
talking and showing this and you're just
going to start seeing some of the sre
practices pop up in your company and
it's just going to continue to evolve
and and we're here we're here to help so
we'll talk about a few ways that you can
engage with Google as I mentioned
earlier I am part of this customer of a
liability team we hope you'll learn how
to SRA in your own team will actually
come in and do workshops do meetings
where we help you set SLO s build your
monitoring build your SRE team itself we
are all sres we've all served on
different teams at Google so we have
some background on how to get the
advocacy how to get the different
structures and of course all of the
technical bits with post-mortems and
things like real and misfortune which is
a exercise we do running through fake
pages with newbies so they are more
comfortable with on call so how to get
to see you CRE is a little more
interesting though because there's not a
lot of us right now
there's twenty thirty of us worldwide
somewhere in there so you're gonna
contact your Tam but you got to keep in
mind your executives your C levels need
to be behind the the process because
again we were talking about the culture
support ultimately if somebody is not
happy they're going to come in escalate
and escalate and they have to be
supported and interestingly CRE is a
group that you don't pay for the
services partly because of our expertise
partly because we're a scarce resource
and but we do you do pay with your
willingness and time so we do expect you
to have homework with each of the
workshops like we may help you build a
few of the s lows we're gonna
back to the rest back we're gonna expect
to see you building the metrics and
showing us the graph so we know that
you're there with us and ready for the
next step cool
so there's also professional services a
group I'm part of we're paid service but
we we come in we can help organizations
by doing kind of intro to sre workshops
or more advanced SLO workshops so you
pick a couple services and we run
through some of the sre models and help
you to find those SLO s
and what would happen if that your era
budget gets exceeded and so forth and it
also could be you know companies that
might not meet the criteria yet for CR
es we could help with that and then
maybe eventually get people like just to
help so again you can contact your sales
or your Tam's or you know ping us we
also have books so we have the site
reliability engineering book that's been
out for a little while the work book
that's just been released so the we've
got some launch day copies over the five
nines so come visit us we've got a bunch
of the series there a few s eries from
other teams as well cool and if you'd
like to start reading that before you
engage us that that is an opportunity to
see if you are on the same page and want
to execute this and seeking s re is
coming soon thank you all
[Music]